S
TRYING TO SCARE US AND THE
PEOPLE.
YOU SEE, IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
SCARE US.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> RUSSIA SAYS ITS ARMED FORCES
HAVE DESTROYED TWO ADVANCED
ROCKET SYSTEMS IN EASTERN
UKRAINE, A CLAIM THAT UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS FLATLY DENY.
RUSSIA SAYS THAT IT ALSO
DESTROYED AMMUNITION DEPOTS ON
THE FRONT LINE IN THE DONETSK
REGION.
KYIV IS ACCUSING RUSSIA OF
AGAIN SPREADING FALSE
INFORMATION.
CNN IS UNABLE TO VERIFY EITHER
CLAIM.
MULTIPLE ROCKET SYSTEMS, THE
U.S. HAS PROMISED TO SEND AID
THEM TO UKRAINE BY JULY.
PHIL BLACK JOINS US NOW WITH
MORE.
PHIL, TALK US THROUGH THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS WEAPON,
BECAUSE FOR SO LONG, WE HAVE
HAD PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY TALK
ABOUT THE NEED FOR A HIGH
CALIBER WEAPON IN TRYING TO WIN
THE BATTLE IN THE EAST OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> INDEED, ISA, UKRAINE HAS
BEEN ASKING THESE FOR A LONG
TIME.
THEY HAVE HAD THEM IN THE FIELD
FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
THEY BELIEVE THEY ARE ALREADY
MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
WE WERE WITH THE MEMBERS OF
THESE UNITS OF MULTIPLE ROCKET
LAUNCH SYSTEMS.
AT THE TIME THAT THEY FIRST
HEARD ABOUT THE RUSSIAN CLAIM
THAT TWO ADULTS HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED.
THE RESPONSE?
IN OUR PRESENCE, WAS TO LAUGH.
UKRAINE'S MILITARY HAS ALREADY
DISMISSED FALSE PROPAGANDA.
THEY SAY THAT THERE ARE
THRILLED AND GRATEFUL TO HAVE A
NEW SYSTEM.
IT EXPANDS THE CAPABILITIES IN
POWERFUL WAYS.
IT ALLOWS THEM TO HIT KEY
RUSSIAN TARGETS FOR MY GREATEST
SINCE THAN EVER BEFORE.
TAKE A LOOK.
A SECRET LOCATION, A PRECIOUS
WEAPON, THE HIGH MOBILITY
ARTILLERY SYSTEM, OR HYMA, A
POWERFUL GIFT FROM THE U.S. TO
UKRAINE.
SO FAR, THEY HAVE ONLY RECEIVED
FOUR LAUNCHERS BUT THE SCORCHED
MARKS ON THE EARTH SHOW THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN BUSY.
THE COMMANDER, ALEXANDER, SAYS
THAT THE LAUNCHERS ARE NOW
UKRAINE'S MOST IMPORTANT
WEAPONS.
>> HE SAYS, IT'S PRECISE,
DEADLY AND THE RUSSIANS SHOULD
FEAR IT.
>> THE OPERATORS SAY THAT IT'S
ACCURACY AND RANGE, ABOUT 44
MILES, ALLOWS IT TO HIT
IMPORTANT SITES DEEP INSIDE
RUSSIAN CONTROLLED TERRITORY.
[NOISE] >> MOSTLY COMMAND POSTS,
WEAPONS AND AMMUNITION STORAGE.
OFFICIALLY, UKRAINE CONFIRMS A
FEW AND A HIGH MARK STRIKES.
THE EVIDENCE IS OUT THERE.
AFTER EACH LAUNCH, THEY MINE
RUSSIAN NEW SITES AND SOCIAL
MEDIA TO SEE THE IMPACT OF
THEIR WORK.
>> ALEXANDER SAYS 20 MINUTES
AFTER THEIR JOB IS DONE, ALL
THE INFORMATION IS PUBLIC.
THERE WAS NO COMMENT FROM
UKRAINE OVER THE CAUSE OF THIS
HUGE EXPLOSION AT A WEAPONS
DEPOTS CLOSE TO THE RUSSIAN
BORDER.
THE LOCAL PRO RUSSIAN FORCES
WERE IGNORED OUT, ONLY UKRAINE
KNEW I MUST COULD'VE DONE THIS.
>> THE SYSTEM'S JOB IS TO TAKE
OUT HIGH VALUE RUSSIAN TARGETS.
THE UKRAINIANS KNOW THAT THIS
IS A HIGH PRIORITY TARGET FOR
THE RUSSIANS.
A LOT OF CARE IS BEING TAKEN TO
ENSURE IT STAYS SAFE PROTECTED
FROM RUSSIAN EYES AND WEAPONS.
>> SOMEWHERE IN THE WOODS AND
FIELDS NEARBY, AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS AND A SPECIAL GROUND
OPERATION ARE GATHERING AT THE
SITE.
THEY ARE ALL MOVING CONSTANTLY.
NEVER STAYING LONGER THAN A DAY
IN ONE LOCATION.
IN ANOTHER SITE, WITH A HIGH
ABILITY TO INFLUENCE THE WAR,
UKRAINIAN LEADERS CANNOT STOP
SAYING, THANK YOU.
NO OTHER DONATED WEAPON HAS
INSPIRED SO MUCH PUBLIC
ATTITUDE.
THE PRESIDENT, DEFENSE MINISTER
AND THE MILITARY.
>> THIS COMMANDER WANTS TO
THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN FOR PROVIDING A
WEAPON THAT IS HELPING UKRAINE
STAY IN THE FIGHT.
BUT HE AND EVERY OTHER SOLDIER
HERE KNOWS THAT RUSSIA STILL
HAS THE MOMENTUM IN THE WAR.
THAT IS WHY THEIR MESSAGE TO
THEIR ALLIES IS UNCHANGED.
[NOISE] >> PLEASE SEND MORE
WEAPONS, NOW.
ISA, UKRAINE HAS HAD THE SYSTEM
FOR TEN DAYS.
THEIR CREWS TELL US THEY ARE
USING THE MORALE AROUND THE
CLOCK.
THEY ARE GETTING BY WITHOUT
SLEEP, TRYING TO DO AS MUCH
DAMAGE TO RUSSIA AS POSSIBLE.
THEY BELIEVE THE HARDER THEY
WORK, THE GREATER THE RELIEF
THAT WILL BRING TO UKRAINE'S
DEFENDERS ON THE FRONT LINES.
THAT IS REALLY THE IDEA AROUND
THE WEAPONS, USE THEIR
CAPABILITIES TO DESTROY ENOUGH
OF RUSSIA'S SUPPORT IN SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE FURTHER FROM THE
FRONT LINE, AND, EVENTUALLY,
RUSSIA